こんにちははじめ社長です
なんか最近安3日ん3階
わかんないけどなんかよくヒカキンさんと動画がかぶるんですよねそれは別に
いいんですけどなんかよくコメントで最近1計算のパクリっていうのはすごい多くて
ちょっとそこ
コースこうですよちょっと
こんな感じで本当にこの投稿に見ても
拙者の方が速い奴も結構あるし
なんでちゃんと
そういうのを見てからコメントして欲しいと思いますガーダ何何やりたいか
なんていうか新商品は多分すっごい
早く出してるんでー
まずパクってないですよ
か食ったっていうそこなんですよ
投稿者ちゃんと見てから言いなさい
本当にもこれですよ
かべったとしても
そんなにじいちゃん他の人がかぶらないように動画ああ
出す
という几帳面なこともよって二次めんどくさいからしないし他の人と比べられても困り
ます
ばっくりパクリいう人
古瀬した金さんパクってないし
ビートボックスまで来ないし
どっちが早くてどっちよハグって何かどっちが被らせたとかそういうのは書けないと
思いますよ
塘路した月少ない僕が言うのもあれですけど
ちょっとそこはあ
最近コメントが多くて
帰ってくださいって感じです
すごいそここれねー
辛い族アーサー格好
こういうのパクリって言うんですよ本当なんだ最近コメント欄が荒れてん
ちょっつらつらターン釣れたんだ僕
ローソンのパンっておいしいんですよぜひ食べてみてください
こういうてがすごい滑らかです
チョコの味が濃くて僕メンタルが弱いんですよ
何
これねっていうか
これと絶妙にマッチしててメンタルヘルスケアしたいぐらいなんですよ
こんな感じです
もう
あれですから
マイスタイルでいきますから
他の人とかべったーとかなんかあくりのか
もう子にしてないんだよボケだしたいって思ったことをして
うまいと思ったもものを何言って紹介してまずいって思ったものをまずいって言うもう
何か
本当にも
僕の動画なんだよ何でしょうか買ってですって思っていました
アンチなんかもチビしてませんからそういうコメントが多くて
こういう場で言わせてもらいました
今日は早く寝てあの女だ
リアル鬼ごっこを見て
出て
いやのコメント全文は添えて
明日から
ほする抗議に行ってきますじゃあ
ん